demant l'illustration du non respect des
gestes barrières avec ce rassemblement à
nice regard des près de 5000 personnes
qui ont assisté à un concert sur la
promenade des anglais
du côté de la mairie monde on se défend
de toute négligence et on assure avoir
respecté la réglementation en vigueur le
maire de nice christian estrosi demande
une clarification des consignes de la
part du gouvernement
l'événement d'hier à nice respecter les
consignes gouvernementales comme l'a
indiqué la préfecture
comptage pour respect de la jauge de
5000 consignes de distanciation rappeler
via messages audio et signalétique et
masques fortement recommandée nous
regrettons que ces consignes n'ait pas
été suffisamment respectés et demandons
à l'état de revoir le décret qui régit
les grands événements afin d'imposer le
port du masque même à l'extérieur
à nice il sera désormais obligatoire
pour tous nos événements